to me the most interesting use case is
to use gen AI to create a sort of a
baseline storytelling for data analysis
I see a lot of potential benefits in the
education space across many domains
helping people from all skill levels
break down complex topics through a
natural q a experience is fantastic
being able to ask for examples with
unlimited follow-up questions is an
excellent resource for acquiring New
Concepts or domain-specific language and
Test new skills I expect to see gen AI
enabled features everywhere in our
day-to-day both at the workplace and at
home from better experiences with
recommendation engines to how we consume
all types of content for work education
or entertainment I expect to see better
integrated experiences powered by Gene
AI very soon